of the most surreal experiences i've
ever had
in a war zone was when we flew to
yemen's capital sanaa
as we were landing we were greeted
looking out the window with
rows and rows kilometers of destroyed
aircraft
passenger jets like our own obliterated
where they stood by the saudi-led
coalition
not a site you want to see when you were
coming into land
that was in the early days of the war
before the death toll
spiraled into the hundreds of thousands
[Music]
time
like all wars the war in yemen is
complicated
the gist of it is after the arab spring
toppled a dictator who had ruled
for three decades his replacement was
his vice
president who happened to be very
pro-saudi
people revolted again so he ran to saudi
arabia
and asked them to invade his own country
to get him back into power hundreds of
thousands of dead later
it's a blood blood-soaked stalemate and
desperation for victory
the sides have resorted to desperate
measures
fighting forces on both sides have
suffered heavy losses in this
unnecessary battle
i see shocking reports as i am sure we
all do
of children increasingly getting drawn
into the war effort and deprived of
their future
yemen is the battleground between saudi
arabia
and iran both support different sides
both are desperate to win in fact the
coalition led by
saudi arabia has enacted a blockade of
yemen
vessels with food and medicine as seized
and arrested starvation is rife
this year more than two million children
will go hungry about a quarter of them
are projected to starve to death
four hundred thousand under the age of
five will die
this year feminine-like conditions are
emerging across yemen and the answer is
simple we have a vaccine for this
it's called food how we need to save
lives is funding
you need only a couple of things to stop
this
about two billion dollars in funding
just peanuts when you consider how many
lives could be saved and at least a
temporary piece
to get the food to the people so the
saudis have
proposed a ceasefire with a lot of fine
print which the houthi rebels rejected
we've announced the strategic initiative
to address all current problems and move
towards a comprehensive political
solution to the yemeni crisis
and hostilities resolve humanitarian
issues
and instill hope for all yemeni people
across the country
saudi arabia is our number one enemy and
their offer
won't serve the interests of the yemeni
people they are only trying to use
media propaganda to get what they were
not able to acquire with arms
and no doubt we are not accepting this
offer
given the depths that the belligerents
have sunk to to gain
any advantage in this war it's difficult
to imagine
peace any time soon armies of saudi
mercenaries would have to be removed
bombs and mines that will take decades
to clear
legions of child soldiers that would
have to be disarmed
and rehabilitated vast parts of the
country
that would have to be rebuilt the
humanitarian
crisis in yemen has been forgotten for
for
quite a time now a war has destroyed
public infrastructure
disrupted livelihoods and public
services yemen needs an immediate
nation's nationwide ceasefire it needs
the international community to come
together and and
push all parties to the conflict to a
common ground because yemenis
have endured unbearable conditions over
the past six years and this
this needs to to end yemen is without a
doubt
the most untalked about humanitarian
catastrophe
unfolding today oh sure once in a while
some
leader pays leap service to what's
happening pretty words
that sound good on camera this war has
to end
and to underscore our commitment we're
ending
all american support for offensive
operations and the war in yemen
including relevant arms sales pretty
words
after six years of arming advising and
assisting saudi arabia
in yemen the us has decided to pull out
out of offensive operations the u.s navy
is and will continue
to be part of the naval blockade that's
condemning
hundreds of thousands of kids to death
by man-made starvation
this is the worst kind of war the kind
you can't win
you can't lose and you can't end